okay this is a great story and it's one  of modern miracle and science an ancient  form of chewing gum providing new  insights into the life of a young girl  from the Stone Age scientists analyzed  genetic material found on that reaction  so this piece of gums grew 5,700 years  old and it's a piece of heated birch  bark was found in Denmark the girl who  chewed on it then spit it out right so  this is an artist rendering of the girl  they were able to tell what she might  have looked like through her DNA because  it was so well preserved scientists  determined she had blue eyes and dark  brown hair they could also tell her most  recent meal included duck and hazelnuts  that's amazing tell amazed we want to  know that why  [Laughter]